what treatise is grow a tree mm-hmm corn
Oh
my favorite fast-food nachos are
actually Chipotle Chipotle is gonna have
the best at eleven might pull through no
the tortilla looks fresh a lot of these
chips are pretty hot versed in the
cheese Department Nathan's really good
cheese he's got Chipotle cheese that I
left I can take the lime in there if you
like soft on it whoa suck on it these
look promising this one you can see
there's different types of cheese
doesn't look like Haas a lot of oil
I dig that I'm into it too the cheese is
like a good mixture of kinds of cheeses
makes me want a drink beer I've never
had they'll taco but I feel like this is
all taco they look like they have
density to it not too thin this is like
you could scoop some stuff in this yeah
mmm
crunch this are really tasty oh this is
definitely stole it you're the bully
sometimes I feel like the chip is
overpowering the cheese you can't even
find the cheese in here this is in the
lead I feel like these are 7-eleven off
of that they look really 7-eleven you
what kind of cheese is on this is it
like it's plastic you're so weird
mm spy cheese penis oh I like the spice
that surprised me you look better
because there what's the same fake
cheese but the chips look a lot stronger
these are the widest chips I've ever
seen I like this I was just gonna say if
you like the face liquid cheese you
probably would like these there's not
that you could actually like dip it with
anything I think these are the best
nachos and I think it's much Poland I
also think these were the best and I
also think they're from a chip cookies
are my favorite nachos I got a big big
one that's Taco Bell oh well yeah
Taco Bell you nachos were way better
than I expected them to be
talk about bomb
only he bought he's on you go girl Paco
good for you this is not Mexico but this
is good